Call of Duty warzone modern warfare and
mobile are all getting new content let's
break down all the new stuff coming to
those three games we'll start with the
newest one warzone the battle royale
game is getting four new weapons the 725
shotgun mark 2 carbine rifle 0.5 OGS
pistol and the eb r 14 battle rifle
you'll find them in common and uncommon
varieties on the map also coming to
warzone is a new operator talent the
talent bundle includes talent himself
two legendary blueprints and to battle
pass tier skips perhaps most importantly
he fights alongside his faithful dog
Indiana who takes the lead during talons
finishing move Talon is playable in both
warzone and modern warfare and modern
warfare is also getting a free new map
it's called candor hideout and it
supports 6v6 matches the maps layout is
perfect for using snipers shotguns NS
mgs both warzone and modern warfare have
also brought back the defender pack for
ten US dollars or nine pounds you'll get
a custom 357 revolver with a rail
mounted sight lightweight trigger and
stippled grip special weapon camo and an
operator watch calling card emblems logo
sticker and two sprays all of which
feature the endowment logo Activision's
endowment charity helps veterans find
jobs after their military careers and a
hundred percent of the proceeds from
this DLC pack goes to that cause finally
let's talk about Call of Duty mobile
because it's getting two new modes the
first is called rapid fire which runs
until Thursday March 26th rapid fire
gives everyone unlimited ammo and you'll
earn operator skills and killstreaks
much faster on top of that the other
mode is sticks and stones which is quite
different you have a limited loadout
usually just a crossbow and throwing axe
and compete for the most points but
here's the thing
death resets your score now two new
modes and mobile does mean we're losing
an old one
zombies will be removed as of Wednesday
March 25th the limited time mode may
return in the future so stay tuned a
game spot for any news on that plus the
latest on the shooter series overall
you